on Wednesday the New York Times issued
an editorial filled with impotent rage
and unexplored angst over president
Trump Supreme Court nomination of Judge
Nino Gorsuch of the Tenth Circuit Court
of Appeals they called Gore such as seat
a stolen seat since Republicans refused
to grant Democrats an up-or-down vote on
judge Merrick garland President Obama's
nominee to fill Antonin Scalia seat
instead of recognizing that the
Constitution gives the Senate the
ability to determine whether to vote on
a given candidate or not the time
suggested that Senate Republicans quote
took an empty Supreme Court seat hostage
inaccurate since usually there's a
ransom demand with hostage and
Republicans didn't have one then the x
characterized scores such a man
unanimously approved for the Tenth
Circuit by a Senate that included Barack
Obama and Joe Biden as extreme of course
here's the New York Times quote
President Obama had a great opportunity
to repair some of that damage by
nominating a moderate candidate for the
vacancy which was created when Justice
Antonin Antonin Scalia died last
february-- instead he chose Neil Gorsuch
a very conservative judge from the
federal court of appeals for the Tenth
Circuit whose jurisprudence and writing
style are often compared to those of
Scalia you mean Republicans appointed
someone like Scalia to fill his seat
what horror The Times acknowledged then
normally they'd have no leg to stand on
with regard to complaining about Gorsuch
but these they say are not normal times
the destructive lesson Senate
Republicans taught is that obstruction
pays off yes it does that's part of the
constitutional system and that's not
actually a problem the give and take the
grind and groan of politics that's how
the system is supposed to work if
Democrats don't like the outcome tough
The Times is actually upset that the
Supreme Court may no longer be a super
legislature of leftist rewriting the
Constitution to fit leftist ends here's
the real complaint quote if judge
Gorsuch is confirmed the court will once
again have a majority of justices
appointed by Republican presidents as it
has for nearly half a century for
starters that spells big trouble for
public sector unions and environment
regulations and women's access to
contraception if Trump gets a chance to
name another Justice the consequences
could be much more dire or maybe
Democrats could stop passing
unconstitutional laws and demanding that
the Supreme Court greenlight them but
that would be asking Democrats to you
know stop being Democrats perhaps most
foolish suggestion from the time is the
notion that Trump should actually govern
like Hillary Clinton after beating her
why because he refuses to quote
acknowledge his historic unpopularity
and his nearly 3 million volt lost to
Hillary Clinton a wiser president faced
with such circumstances would govern
with humility and respect for the views
of all Americans unquote if the
situation were reversed as anyone think
the times would be calling for Hillary's
nominated moderate or would be pushing
for a gung-ho revision of the
Constitution by a judicial Fiat
proclaiming a win is a win well Trump
promised to texture was to the court he
won he fulfilled that promise the Senate
is doing its job The Times is doing its
job to whining endlessly an incoherent
fashion about losing I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show yes what
you're seeing is reality that's right
see a bet is a bet and when I make bets
with cultural correspondent Michael
Knowles about whether Donald Trump is
actually going to appoint a conservative
to the court and then I lose I fulfill
my end of the bed now all I ask is that
if I end up being right when Trump does
bad things than other people recognize
that's true but I am honest I was wrong
I was totally wrong about this I said
there was zero chance the Trump would
nominate a textualist to the court
because he didn't really care about the
court and also because Mitch McConnell
was not going to invoke the nuclear
option we'll see about McConnell but I
have never been happier to be wrong
Donald Trump's pic of Neil Gorsuch is an
excellent excellent pic good for Donald
Trump for proving me wrong I hope he
continues to do so we'll get to all that
in a second first yes say thank you to
our sponsors today over at blue apron so
if you're somebody who is interested in
cooking your own meals but you don't
know what recipes to use and you don't
want to go shopping for the ingredients
that really is the most time-consuming
part going to the market and trying to
find all the fresh ingredients trying to
figure out what the recipe actually says
blue apron solves all of that for you so
they have a new recipe every single day
and they give you they actually send you
the ingredients packaged for your house
they send you three free meals free
right now with free shipping if you go
to blue apron calm right now / Shapiro
blue aprons calm / Shapiro it's less
than ten bucks per person per meal all
of the meals are cooked in less than 40
minutes and it's flexible you can redo
recipes you like you can discard recipes
that you don't every one of them comes
with a step-by-step easy-to-follow
recipe card and every ingredient is
fresh a lot of my friends are using blue
apron they all say that it's fantastic
they say the food that comes out is
great and
it all tastes fresh and you can also
tailor the recipes to your own liking
because they send you the recipe but if
your kitchen so you can do what you want
blue apron is a better way to cook again
it saves you the trouble of the shopping
and figuring out of the recipes and
everything is super fresh in right now
blue apron calm flash Shapiro blue apron
calm / Shapiro use flash Shapiro so they
know that we sent you plus if you do you
get three meals free right now and
they're their meal list is really
terrific I mean their upcoming meals is
mushroom and chipotle pepper enchilada
with lime and sour cream it's like
gourmet stuff and you can make it in
your own kitchen really first-rate
according to everybody I know who uses
it and it's taking over LA so check it
out blue aprons calm / Shapiro okay so
the big news of the day of course is
that Donald Trump fulfills his promise
and as I said and I will repeat I got it
wrong and I am very very happy that I
got it wrong I said right after Trump
was elected that I was that I would be
more than overjoyed if Trump would prove
me wrong on things and this is something
he proved me wrong about he went out
then he picked an astral tech in actual
textualist and so in honor of michael
moses feeding me in a bet instead of
firing him which I actually do
technically have the power to do i
decided to fulfill my end of the bat
also i know that he was he was
celebrating a Donald Trump executive
order that apparently came down last
night that yeah so I'm not going to pay
up on all our bet that's so he can just
forget about that that's not going to
happen for those who are listening this
later it's Donald Trump signing an
executive order that says I'm going to
pay Michael Knowles eight hundred
dollars or four hundred dollars that's
that's not happening again he should
just be happy that he escaped firing for
being correct on this in any case we'll
start with with with judge Gorsuch so
judge donald trump comes out and let
yesterday's a whole bunch of how about
because it comes down to tom is Hardiman
from the Tenth Circuit Court of Appeals
versus judge neil Gorsuch or hard
minutes from the Seventh Circuit i
believe and gore search from the Tenth
Circuit Court of Appeals and so Hardiman
has no record there's no long-standing
kind of judicial philosophy you can
attribute to Hartman and Hardman is
recommended by Trump sisters so all of
the signs there 4.2 Hardiman instead you
explore such very very smart move smart
move for a number of reasons politically
it's very smart because it sure
his bass drums had a chaotic first 10
days to say the least and this Shores up
his base I would not be surprised if in
the next couple of weeks Donald Trump
starts to push something like a
trillion-dollar infrastructure package
thing look I gave you your judge now
give me my infrastructure package that
would be the smart political move if he
wants to triangulate so just pointing
that out now but you got to be overjoyed
if you're a conservative about judge
Gorsuch now I want to get one other
thing out of the way here and that is
everybody is already breaking out the
chisels for Rushmore for Trump because
of all of this wasn't a great thing is a
great thing I'm wearing the freaking hat
what do you want from me okay it's
terrific you know good things happen and
that's that's fantastic and good for
Trump again for the ninth time already
in the first four minutes of the program
I was wrong about this so good for non
old Trump now there's a player on the
Colorado Rockies last year and there was
Trevor story in the first three games he
had home runs did he finish with 162
home runs okay this is one of the
mistakes people make in evaluating
sports oh he goes on a hot streak and
the ideas they're never going to miss
again listen I'm happy to evaluate
Donald Trump in two years and determine
whether his presidency is a success or a
failure in the first ten days so far
it's a wild success obviously okay so
we'll determine in two years whether it
is an overall success or failure at that
point then you will get an ultimate I
was wrong from me if I was wrong I'm not
going to say that yet because we're 10
days in for God's sake okay Trevor story
is not babe ruth he finished the season
with 27 home runs he did not finish with
162 home runs but when a good thing
happens a good thing happens okay so
here is Donna so Donald Trump does
leading up to this a lot of people think
he is going to do which is he brings in
Hardiman and then he brings in Gorsuch
and then they think there's going to be
an actual rose ceremony and so the media
is all abuzz with this and then it turns
out that Trump actually does something
great not just picking Gorsuch doing it
in a dignified way she has the ceremony
last night where hands the roads to
Gorsuch basically but it's really
signified it's really low key he does it
professionally here's Donald Trump
introducing judge Gorsuch when Justice
Scalia passed away suddenly less cub
worry I made a promise to the American
people if I were elected president I
would find the very best judge in the
country for the Supreme Court I promised
to select someone who respects our laws
and is representative of our
Constitution and who loves our
Constitution and someone who will
interpret them as written okay I don't
know who's writing a stuff for him but
it's great okay this is all terrific and
again so i think the Trump deeply cares
about this stuff no but I don't care
whether he cares about the stuff since
all i care about is the result right i
don't care about what is thinking
processes the result is great and the
result is judge Gorsuch the Gorsuch then
comes to the stage and here's a Gorsuch
has to say about the Constitution
standing here in a house of history and
acutely aware of my own imperfection I
pledge the divine confirmed I will do
all my powers permit to be a faithful
servant of the Constitution laws of this
great country okay and then he continues
along those lines by saying he talked
about Justice Scalia who he was friends
with he said that he cried when Scalia
died here's what he said about Justice
Scalia the towering judges that have
served in this particular seat of the
Supreme Court including NN Scalia and
Robert Jackson are much in my mind at
this moment Justice Scalia was a lion of
the law and he went on to talk about all
the things you liked about Justice
Scalia now here's what you need to know
about Gorsuch so the reason I'm excited
about flora section and I have actually
do have a good track record as far as
picking Supreme Court judges I'm the
only person that I know who came out
against Justice Roberts because I said
that Roberts didn't have enough of
record I like Gorsuch I think course
which is going to be very much like
Alito he'll actually be to the right of
a litto and the reason I say this is
because from what we can tell from what
we can tell based on the best available
evidence this is a guy who actually has
a coherent judicial philosophy and his
judicial philosophy is that you ought to
read the Constitution as it was meant
when it was written that's his
philosophy which is Scalia's philosophy
as well so he's great on a lot of issues
so he ruled that Obamacare could not
stamp on the on the Little Sisters of
the Poor for example he was on the court
that ruled that the appeals court that
ruled that here's what he wrote in that
case quote all of us face the problem of
complicity all of us must answer for
ourselves whether and to what degree we
are willing to be involved in the
wrongdoing of others for some religion
provides an essential source of guidance
both about what constitutes wrongful
conduct and the degree to which those
who assist others
committing wrongful conduct themselves
their moral culpability this statute
violates their faith representing a
degree of complicity to religion this
allows he's also ruled that the Ten
Commandments is not establishment of
religion in violation of the
Constitution when put in public places
which is obvious he stood in favor of
the constitutionality of the death
penalty he's ruled in favor of strength
and second Amendment rights and here's
what he wrote in 2005 at National Review
quote American liberals have become
addicted to the courtroom relying on
judges and lawyers rather than elected
leaders in the ballot box as the primary
means of effecting their social agenda
on everything from gay marriage to
assisted suicide to the use of vouchers
for private school education this
overweening addiction to the courtroom
as the place to debate social policy is
bad for the country and bad for the
judiciary forces has said in the lecture
just last april thats coolio's career
reminds us of the difference between
judges and legislators he says judges it
should not be looking to appeal to their
own moral convictions but instead should
apply the law as it is focusing backward
not forward that's important because
very often you see people on the left of
the court say that the law is designed
to allow judges to look forward he's
saying we have to focus backward not
forward looking to the text structure
and history to decide what a reasonable
reader at the time of the events in
question would have understood the law
to be not to decide cases based on their
own moral convictions or the policy
consequences they believe might serve
society best that's a pretty hard slap
in that lecture at Justice Roberts who
rewrote the law in Obamacare in order to
achieve a result that he thought was
that in one area actually gorse which is
better than Scalia he's not as good a
writer as Scalia because Scalia is one
of the great judicial writers of all
time but in one area he's better and
that's what they call Chevron deference
so Chevron deference is the case from
1984 I believe is called Chevron and
basic case was that there was an
environmental regulation that was
interpreted by the EPA in a certain way
and people sued and they said the EPA is
interpreting this law wrong and the EPA
judged that those people were wrong to
these people into court issued the EPA
and the EPA said listen we're the ones
task of interpreting the law our
interpretation is reasonable you don't
get to review our interpretation of the
law because our interpretation is
reasonable and the court said okay
gorsuch does something different he says
no that that allows for impermissible
abdication of duty by Congress the
Congress were to send the law
out of the epa saying we want you to
interpret all environmental policy that
doesn't now mean that the EPA gets to be
its own legislature it's Congress has
dropped to pass laws it's the executives
branch to implement them if the
executive branch implements them in ways
that are not according to what a
reasonable definition of the statute
would be then the jury she did you dish
iary can the judiciary can overrule them
if they don't put the most reasonable
interpretation the judiciary can
overrule them in 2016 he said quote at
the chevron rule excuse me some permits
executive brewer aqua sees to swallow
huge amounts of core judicial and
legislative power and concentrate
federal power in a way that seems more
than a little difficult to square with
the constitution of the framers design
he's also a federalist his big fan of
states rights so Gorsuch is a terrific
back there is there I don't see any
particular red flags for Gore such as
opposed to a lot of the the other judges
who have been named even prior had some
red flags i think or such as a cleaner
record but we'll see you know in the
hearings it may be that red flag will
crop up but i don't see anything wrong
with course it's good for Donald Trump
good for Donald Trump good for Donald
Trump this is a home run pick for Donald
Trump I'm not sure that he could have
done any better and he again he comes to
conclusions Gorsuch does based on the
law and not based on what he would want
the law to be which sometimes means the
conservatives aren't going to like the
outcome but that's not what the Supreme
Court is for the Supreme Court is not
just to get a conservative outcome it's
to get a constitutional outcome he's a
he voted the right way on hobby lobby
most important for for Trump's purposes
she was easily confirmed in 2006 he was
confirmed unanimously they didn't even
take a roll call vote they took a voice
vote on Gorsuch which means Obama voted
for him Biden voted for him they all
voted for him okay we have to pause and
say thank you to another one of our
advertisers so if you love podcast and
you're interested in listening to
fictional podcasts that which are great
i like and i enjoy the entertainment
podcast side of the of the internet as
well there's a great one from wandering
called secrets crimes and audiotapes
it's a wonder you can get the stitcher
the Wonder a app on android wherever you
listen to podcast its secrets crimes and
audio tape on itunes so every week they
drop a new episode and they do a whole
series of audio dramas so right now
they're due
one by Margaret Atwood called The
Handmaid's Tale which is about this
dystopian future where the government of
the United States has been overthrown
and replaced with this this tyranny and
the tyranny has some implications
particularly for women The Handmaid's
Tale it's worth listening to and and
it's certainly politically it's
certainly political hot button issue
story i'll have to critique it at some
point the actual handmaids tale from
Margaret Atwood but they do a beautiful
job really producing it and making it
sound professional and making an
entertaining and awesome so it's been
removed so that again right now it's
called The Handmaid's Tale is that the
story they're doing but the actual
podcast which then they changed the
story every few weeks the actual podcast
is secrets crimes and audio tapes make
sure you go to subscribe right now
wherever you listen to podcast secrets
crimes and audio tapes go check it out
right now okay so Republicans naturally
are responding to all of this with with
great excitement as well they should so
Ted Cruz comes out he says neil course
which is a home run he's absolutely
right and tonight President Trump
honored that commitment he follows
through on the commitment I made I think
George judge Korsak is a home run he has
a decade of proven experience on the
court of appeals being faithful to the
Constitution following the law
protecting the bill of rights and our
fundamental liberties and I think that
record will yield a swift confirmation
in the United States Senate and we'll
find out about the swift confirmation
but to talk about what the Democrats are
going to do about this you're going to
have to go over today lee weyer calm
right now and subscribe if you want to
watch the rest of this episode with me
being humiliated by wearing the mag i
hat then you're going to have to go over
and subscribe right now eight dollars a
month will get you that will get you the
pleasure of my pain and you can also get
the annual subscription right now you
get a free copy signed copy of my book
true allegiance and you can go over and
check it out right now or you can listen
later and itunes and soundcloud and then
check it out there we are the largest
conservative podcast in the united
states
[Music]
you